you had honestly my favorite scenes in
this movie you were so so funny I just
need to know you know it's one thing to
have a scene or have a couple of scenes
with these four iconic women in
Hollywood but you had a dance scene with
them what was that like it was so much
fun you know it was choreographed by a
choreographer and
you know the ladies came ready
the dancers came ready and it was it was
so organic and magical because you know
they said action and it just fell into
place
you know and it was it was it's just as
as you received it it was just as fun
doing it
I can only imagine what who out of the
four ladies really impressed with their
moves the most
um you know I don't do the competition
thing
they were all amazing
every one of them has their own you know
little space and little moment of what
they do as you see you pull you know
that you get shots of all of them they
were all magical very quiet I love that
I love that well I can only imagine too
you know someone like Rita Moreno and
and the work she's done on Broadway the
musical films the iconic roles and then
you have this hilarious scene with her
this poker scene um what surprised you
the most working with her
um
how naughty she is
she's naughty tell me everything she's
naughty she's
you know she's abroad as we as you know
I don't know if that's still a term you
know but they're all broads you know
what I mean like old school bronze and
you know
she talks about the boys a lot
she talks about the boys a lot that was
surprising it's fun because I got the
boys a lot too right you got some fun
stories that's amazing so we have a lot
to talk about
I love that so much
um you know all four women love uh Tom
Brady not only in real life but
obviously their characters really draw
inspiration from him I was just curious
for you uh and being in this industry is
there someone that you were just
completely awestruck by or someone
that's really inspired you in this
industry
[Music]
okay
oh yeah
um you know I grew up singing in the
church and singing was the first
Artic artistic thing that I knew I had
talent in and you know I wanted to be
the male Whitney Houston
um that dream sort of came true is that
yeah have played the Fairy Godmother in
a Cinderella
um but uh
you know I just loved her I loved who
she was I loved
what she represented and I miss her a
lot yeah oh I love that answer so much
um obviously we have Rana performing at
the Super Bowl halftime show everyone's
really excited for that do you have a
standout halftime show that you will
always remember
Diana Ross
I don't remember what year it was but it
was a full gag
because she was in the middle she was
towards the end of her thing I don't she
was singing oh I Will Survive
oh I Will Survive and they were in a
they were in a vamp and she looks up and
she goes here comes my ride and it's a
helicopter
lands on the stage she sits in it they
they put the little thing on she wraps
her hands in the thing and they lift off
and see what I it is I said when I do my
halftime show that's my exit I'm still
in there
and you know I'm not a sports person I
watch the I watch I've watched the Super
Bowl for the concert of course I that's
what I do for it and when the Steelers
are on I watch okay oh okay gotcha
Steelers fan perfect
um you were so much fun to talk to great
in this film so nice talking to you nice
to talk to you too